jackass Entertainer stunt man and
apparently Taco lover we man joining us
here this morning and we are talking
tacos you just hear that sound and I get
excited we got the jackass oh yeah yeah
okay so tacos Chronic Taco 20 years 20
years so you're gonna be meeting in
greeting fans of tacos and yourself yeah
totally so it's tomorrow tomorrow from
one to three at the Palms okay we have a
restaurant there right in the food court
so we've been there we've been there for
a few years and tacos I mean yeah tacos
burritos anything so what made you
decide that this was a good Venture for
your business
um a buddy of mine a close friend of
mine came to me and said hey we need to
bring this Taco uh shop Chronic Tacos
into our area okay and I go well you
figure it out and let me know and uh he
goes all right so he went of the
locations got a hold of Randy the
founder and he's like no way you don't
have wee man that wants to you know join
with us and my buddy goes yeah and we
went out for dinner one night you know
and it was kind of cordial and they were
like what are you doing let's go have a
couple drinks and then see if we can
connect and we had a good time and I'm
like I'm in here and he's like I'm in
okay well what's your favorite Taco uh
my favorite's the AL past store oh yeah
okay sweet and spicy pork good pineapple
I think there's vegan tacos too vegan
okay plant-based meat we have potato
tacos we have everything for everybody
you've got it okay so folks come and see
we man that's going to be tomorrow
inside the Palms food court at Chronic
Tacos and of course now I have to ask
you because jackass forever is out yes
every time I watch a clip I'm just
laughing you've been doing this now for
20 plus years I mean any regrets no not
one not regrets of some things I didn't
do no kidding yes okay so but not
regrets of everything I've done it's a
fun life yeah dangerous though yeah yeah
but that's what makes it it you know
that's right people love us because they
feel like they're part of us well I
think you you've kind of you've opened
the floodgates to let us see everything
behind the scenes
Stevo just came out with the book yeah
uh what do you think you're gonna write
a book someday uh I hope so I'm trying
to get a hold of this uh lady who did an
interview with me for the New York Times
I love the way she wrote so I'd love to
co-author it with her oh Grace okay this
is something we can look forward to
maybe
and um and what else is in the pipeline
for you I mean tacos movies may be a
book you're still skateboarding still
skateboarding still doing whatever I
want
um I don't know I'm always it I go day
by day and I'm always like in a hurry to
do the next thing or whatever and so but
we're on this 20-year tour for Chronic
Tacos right now so it's kind of taking
up my time that is but we'll see it's
all tacos all the time tacos all the
time awesome okay so again go see we man
tomorrow at the Palms Chronic Tacos one
to three we appreciate your time it was
so fun having you here he got up early
and his mom lives here so he's kind of
local yeah yeah okay so you set that
alarm you come in anytime you want and
we'll let Sherry do the weather now
because you guys are fun